a soldier the size of an insect the
ultimate secret weapon Scott you're
different be skillful and agile fast I
need you to be the ant-man make sense
awesome the suit has power you have to
learn how to control it you tried to
hide your suit from me now
it's gonna blow up in your face pick on
someone your own size
there's no reason to be scared oh no no
daddy don't get scared Billy how'd you
do that bro look at your shoulder
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
ant-man trailer so there's gonna be a
breakdown of that just a reminder the
movies coming out July 17th that's the
week after Comic Con so there's probably
gonna be a bunch more ant-man footage
that's coming in the next couple weeks
and the reason that this movie is a big
deal not only because it's the official
ending of phase 2 but it's also the
beginning of like the next new Avenger
even though the story is all about Scott
Lang's Redemption I mean there's a lot
of hope Van Dyne in there that I'll talk
about in a second but it's the idea that
the average person could become an
Avenger you know like break through til
I like top tier a list it's also gonna
widen the scope of the types of stories
that Marvel can tell on these bigger
Avengers films namely heist stories
because that's I mean that's what this
movie is a man in the context of the way
his powers were compared to the other
Avengers would be more of like a point
man you know you send him him to scope
stuff out we even see him traveling
through circuitry in the movie that's
what all these electrical charges are
like he's travelling through electrical
circuits if you send in someone like the
vision you know he'll just like phase
right through stuff Thor would just
smash his way through just like the Hulk
ant-man is someone you use for more
delicate procedures the film itself is a
bigger risk the Marvel has taken before
just just because the characters are so
odd there's you know so different than
like it's typical a list Avenger films
like you look at Chris Evans you know
mr. Dorito here he looks like a hero
Scott Lang definitely does not look like
a hero Evangeline Lilly looks like way
more of a hero than Paul Rudd does in
the film she's like the stick to Scott
Lang's daredevil what hasn't really come
across in the last couple of trailers
they afford is that Scott Lang really
only steals to support his daughter he's
estranged from her mother but he still
loves his daughter so much that you know
so he steals to support her in the
comics is because she was sick she
needed money for doctors so it's not
like he's stealing because he's a
dirtbag although he is a little bit of a
dirtbag one of the reasons I think they
chose Michael Douglas tout you know in a
kind of a twist is because of the
characterizations of Hank Pym being not
such a nice guy in the comics and the
types of characters that Michael
Douglas's played like you know Gordon
Gekko from Wall Street very evil
character Gordon Gekko actually would be
a pretty good Marvel villain he'll be
like kingpins financial adviser the
trailers seemed to have been holding
back on that quite a bit because he's
like hey I need you to go into a place
and steal some stuff obviously the real
villain of the film is Darren cross
played by Corey Stoll here
but you know just because they're not a
villain doesn't mean they're not bad
people so don't be surprised if hank pym
comes off as kind of a dick in the film
I mean that's kind of the point
it'll help make Scott Lang a little more
sympathetic we also get a better shot of
Michael Pena in the film too I mean he's
a security guard we saw him in an
earlier trailer working inside Pym tech
the movie itself is gonna be pretty
self-contained you know in the same way
that like Thor movies are self-contained
you know they deal with really big
concepts but this is a much smaller film
much more intimate for those asking
though you know it will reference other
things in Marvel phase 3 it like it will
reference other movies and you know
there's even rumors that they're gonna
reference spider-man in the film I'm not
gonna hold my breath on that most of the
story we'll build thematically on what's
going on in the Marvel Universe like it
in the timeline right now in the wake of
age of Ultron in case it hasn't been
said this movie does pick up after age
of Ultron Marvel films were getting
ready to do that where they start
jumping around at the time light a
little bit like Thor 3 is supposed to
pick up relatively closely to where
Captain America 3 picks up usually the
time line moves sequentially so you
remember when like you know Thor the
dark world came out six months after a
Captain America Winter Soldier in the
timeline that was like six months Marvel
is getting to a place where it's gonna
be releasing three films a year you know
maybe even more than that in future
years so they will get a little wonky
with a timeline I know I said I was
gonna do wasp video so that's probably
gonna happen this week but you know be
sure to subscribe to get that I'm also
gonna be talking about
Evangeline Lilly's character and how I
think that she's going to be the wasp of
the Marvel Universe what they've done
with the yellowjacket in this character
is given that to the villain Darren
cross so yellowjacket just an outright
villain Hank Pym was yellowjacket in the
comics that you know for a brief period
he was evil he just liked it you went a
little crazy there making it way easier
to fall in the film so don't worry about
that
what I think will happen is is they'll
just repurpose the yellowjacket suit and
hopf and I will wear it there are a
couple toys that have spoiled a few
things about Hank PIMs character in the
movie I'm not gonna talk about it here
just because the movie is so close to
coming out anyway but if you guys know
what I'm talking about you want to talk
about in the comments just please use
spoiler tags they're all like really
little things that play on Hank PIMs
characterizations in the comics over the
years for the most part he's like a
crazier insane version of Tony Stark I
actually just did a video about his
history in the comics all I had a link
for that in the description so I believe
I said I was all
working on a Batman video that's
probably gonna be the video that I do
next and then I'll just push my flash
video tomorrow but if there's any
special arrow bonus videos that you guys
want this week just let me know and I'll
do it after my flash stuff while you
guys wait for that stuff to drop you can
click here to learn all about Hank
Pimm's history in the comics and you can
click here for some of the summer TV
shows that I'm gonna be doing stuff for
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you